okay so nervousa is great for learning
uh
just combat strategy okay because the
chance of getting hurt is very very low
right unlike tachiwaza
so
right now what the beginner thinks with
last night's training is that you're
gonna control people
and you're gonna smother them
and all that's all you gotta do okay
when you try to do that in real life
you're gonna just end up muscling it's
not jujitsu either okay
um so let's just uh watch as we observe
this okay
uh so
top guy is going to try to do
yesterday's drill try to get the mount
position
and the bottom guy is
going to try to get out of it reverse it
some other submission some escape
or
get to a weapon
[Music]
okay
okay we'll switch
so the strategy
that the top guy is currently forgetting
is the namesake of the art
non-contestation
okay
so if he's trying to do last night's
drill
i can't move so i don't try to move i
don't try to frame here
or do anything
he's not doing anything to me
so i'm just chilling
okay
this is what we were doing yesterday so
he goes he's trying to do yesterday's
drill
that was yesterday's drill and what i
was doing
was moving into the yin space
he goes
i'm in the beginning
so here's a testicle grab
and you see no energy
okay
so let's say i got
he got the neon
he freed this arm how easy it is and i'm
gonna grab his testicles right bro
what's he probably gonna do he's gonna
give more space do you see and that's
when i use that space
to get out
i didn't push him
to do anything
okay let's go into detail
uh by combining non-contestation
with what was said on top
okay
so i'm on top
and we were saying
that it made no sense
to go from a position of advantage and
lots of control
to start opening it up that would be a
position of disadvantage okay
so
if i have all this control what the
student doesn't understand is
uh we were
practicing or drilling
pressure
you see
and we gave a utility to it you want to
control his arms for weapons and things
like that
but then your mind filled it in with
uh
agency
like you are the person
driving the bus but now you're not in
jiu jitsu
and that's why you end up moving from
position of advantage to position a
disadvantage okay because you're going
to move you're going to open things up
etc etc okay
so
if i'm golden here
it's we're going to ask the question
when do i do that do i just do it
because i want to do it that would not
be jujitsu do you see okay it's not
aikido
the opportunity is going to present
itself just like it does for
the bottom person okay
so
some of the ways that you get that
opportunity
is
it's very uncomfortable for him
they don't like it you see
so he starts moving around he starts
trying to do things
he's trying to get space
whoa
trying to get it trying to get it get it
he's just going i'm just chilling
chilling chilling
on he's going that way i just let him
pass underneath me and i'm on
okay
or
you go for
an attack i go for this attack over here
oh
he goes to defend that attack
right there he goes you see
he's trying to get that
i still have all the advantage
there is much
when he turned into me
there's the lock
you see as opposed to
he's going to be extending his arm like
you're trying to do the law
he turned into me
oh there
okay
uh same way he goes to extend his arm
let him extend his arm he goes into that
one i don't shove his arm open
okay
some of the things you can see
so let's look
beginner
level well when do you do what do you do
what well first start from control
start from pressure okay
because you have to check the arms so
you can't draw a weapon
start from disruptive don't make it
peaceful where he he's going to want to
lay there the whole time do you see you
have to give
some sort of young
energy
to make him want to yield
okay
of course the
the dope
the dope person is going to be muscling
and pushing just let him tire out
everything you're going to do later is
going to be that more effective if he's
fatigued
okay
of course also in his um
in his muscling and muscle and muscling
you see what he did to his neck
so his neck is so cool and you could do
stupid things
and it'll work just fine okay now you
don't need anything you have all the
arms that you have here the carotid or
the bar arm chill okay
okay
but you don't
start doing the opposite or doing what
he's doing okay you don't do the
opposite of jiu-jitsu strategy you don't
you're not going to start
huffing and puffing and
muscling him you just chill okay
everything is trapped so first start
like we did yesterday get as much
control as you can
so he tries to do things okay
if he's not doing anything
well that's a yin
you started going active
you see
and then again don't start going
um
past that activity
okay don't start
like yes you can do it okay but you want
to develop the skill
of allowing the openings to present
themselves okay so that it becomes
effortless
this is going to take muscle look at the
size of that disorder okay but when he
turns into me
takes no money
okay as an example
do you understand okay so first start
with pressure and disruption
and then
wait for them to do things or you guys
are already doing things on the bottom
if they're not doing anything which is
what i would do as the bottom person
start initiating something
from side control okay and then see as
the opportunity presents itself for a
mouth okay
aikido is about letting letting the
opportunity present itself
okay okay
so uh
things become fluid
and you're going to not resist them if
but you're going to maintain the
concepts okay so
when she was with her partner
partner had
good initial control like can you get
your arms out no
she's checking high like this okay
again not not how i would advocate this
because it's just a simple push over
it's going to be another disruptive
okay
but
you don't want to do it because
you're going to pull that arm out you
see then you got to deal with that
weapon
but just go to the next point of control
so can she pull her arm out no she can't
pull her arm out if you can't pull her
arm up can't pull her arm up can't pull
her arm out can't pull her arm up
there
now i can free this arm
you see
and maybe as i go
to do this
this becomes
loose
do you think
but i'm not
that's what i want
okay if it stays there it's because
she's kept it there but i'm looking for
it as i go to do this she goes like that
and now
while she might reach something
she can't do anything with it go back
grab whatever
can't do anything with it right
you can push it
forward still can't do do you feel that
and then you have the more disruption on
your face do you see that
right
okay i'm loosing that because it's
getting hurt
but it's not me squeezing
it's just my weight
going into that
okay
you're like oh you can't can't get up
don't worry about it
you have the arm trapped underneath you
and this arm is just
one step away
so this version here
i don't want to come off
i'm going to do with my head
you have a gokyo do you see the gokyo if
their elbow is not working but believe
me it's working
but you can do both
remember in the same way
as i was transitioning to different
points of control
that your
tactics
are
interdependent that they're looming okay
i don't know how you got there with her
but at some point
she
wasn't necessarily reaching for weapons
but
she had
a bear hug do you remember
and again
looks like
can't get the arms but look boom
boom oh there look there came
okay
and you're gonna get it again you can do
the same one just attack the wrist
so
it only appears to be an obstacle
and
it's a mindset where
you're trying to
not get
blocked
or trying to get out of
obstacles or prevent them from occurring
but that's not jujitsu
as they do their thing it presents an
opportunity which is visible
when you release okay
so when you're rolling that is primarily
the point of rolling
not tapping them out
through any other means then let the
opportunity present itself
find the easy solution okay
then you would train her oh
don't don't put your arms away from your
face because they're just gonna knock me
out and then they're gonna do whatever
they want okay
all right